the freedom of art has played a vital
role in human civilization for centuries
the ancient Greeks were the first to
acknowledge its importance Arica
Ackerman researchers the history of
freedom and for the only Rosalita
dimension the idea of the universality
of Human Rights has its roots in the
French Revolution and the u.s. American
Revolution the ideas arose out of
struggles in Europe and the new world in
America but they were always demands for
universal human rights and for here
algerian writer boo Alan son sal is an
advocate of the freedom of art he now
lives in Paris under police protection
in his latest book 2084 he envisages a
nightmarish society ruled by a
totalitarian religious regime
recognizably founded on fundamentalist
Islamist principles sure 50 for me the
conditions that would allow it to roll
in place there are series crises
unfolding all over the world peyote
who's easy for me tab global threats
allow religious fanatics to claim their
the devil's work God's curse they're
skilled at spreading this sort of
message was learning many more like a
blur booooo lame son Sal has won many
prizes and faces many threats there's a
stream of attacks online in emails and
letters writers in particular stretch
the boundaries of how a society thinks
exposing themselves to great risks of
Telos been an ax in writers play a major
role in these transformation processes
because they can invent alternative
scenarios utopias or confront us maybe
via fiction with drastic visions of what
isn't working in a country or Society
fortson yet
freedom of expression and freedom of art
sometimes require enormous courage but
it's this very courage which helps bring
the individual freedoms which we often
take for granted